[Music]
hello everyone
and welcome to the first lecture on the
epistemology of fake news
okay so let's begin with the first
section
understanding the threat i can imagine
that
just like me many of you have been
following the news unusually closely
lately
and you'll no doubt have heard that
there's a lot of fake news about the
coronavirus
circulating online for example you may
read that bill gates is spreading the
coronavirus
in order to implant microchips in our
brains
you may read that the virus was
engineered as a bio weapon
and that it contains genetic sequences
inserted from hiv
or you may read that 5g mobile networks
are in some way implicated in the
pandemic
either by directly emitting the virus
through some kind of miasma
or by weakening the human immune system
through some kind of high frequency
electromagnetic radiation
if you come down with a cough a fever
and difficulty breathing
and turn to the internet in search of a
cure you face a bewildering array of
options
you may be encouraged to eat large
amounts of garlic ginger or hot peppers
to rub goose fat on your chest to expose
yourself to high temperatures or maybe
to expose yourself to low temperatures
to drink cow's urine or bathing cows
dung
if you had tuned in to alex jones of
infowars a little while ago you would
have been encouraged to gargle with
super blue
silver immune gargle which contains
colloidal silver
and of course as we heard only a few
days ago donald
trump has been taking hydroxychloroquine
a drug developed for the treatment of
malaria
but which still has not been fully
tested for its safety and efficacy in
treating covid19
the list of things i just mentioned is
varied ranging from wild conspiracy
theories to theories that are just
false misleading or lack sufficient
information
supporting evidence
but despite the variation i'm calling
reports of all of these things i just
mentioned fake news
that is to say i'm operating with a
particularly broad definition of the
term
and one that's probably at odds with the
way in which it's used by others
for example trump uses the term fake
news to express antipathy
towards any content that conflicts with
his own beliefs or interests
some might say that trump has tainted
the term by using it this way
but i've decided to stick to it because
this variability in its meaning
actually reflects some of the themes
that i want to discuss
so to be clear what i mean by fake news
is
publicly available content that presents
itself as reliable
factual information but is in fact false
misleading
or at least in some cases produced with
the intention to deceive
so satirical news media such as the
onion or the borowitz report which make
it clear that they're satirical
don't count as fake news by my
definition because they don't present
their content as reliable factual
information
uh public posts websites blogs and the
like all count as fake news if they do
present their content as factual even in
part
and if that content is false or
misleading of course they're going to be
borderline cases but this rough
definition will do
for our purposes what's important is
that fake news is presented as reliable
factual information
when it's really false or misleading
of course fake news has been around for
a long time but as we've all become
acutely aware
fake news travels farther and faster
online than it ever has been able to do
before
so you might ask what does epistemology
have to do with fake news
well epistemology is the philosophical
study of knowledge
and knowledge involves both true belief
and rationality
that is if you know a statement p then
it follows that you have a true belief
that p
and you have reached that belief in the
right kind of way that is in a way
that's rational or reliable
or is based appropriately on reasons or
evidence
if you believe something true but you
don't have any reasons or evidence for
your belief then your belief is just a
lucky guess
and doesn't amount to knowledge and what
i want to talk about today
are some of the threats fake news poses
towards knowledge
of course there is the obvious threat
that fake news poses towards knowledge
since you know something only if you
have a true belief
if you're misled by fake news into
believing something false
then obviously you lack knowledge but
there are
further less obvious ways in which fake
news poses a threat to knowledge
and i'm going to discuss three of these
less obvious threats to knowledge
which i've listed on your handout they
are the threat from irrationality
the threat from rational polarization
and the threat from
relativism so first let me say something
a little bit about the threat from
irrationality
a striking feature of our current
situation is that fake news seems to go
hand in hand with political polarization
when groups on either side of a
political spectrum move further and
further apart from one another
this kind of political polarization of
factual belief is hardly new to the u.s
where conservatives and liberals are
polarized over all sorts of empirical
matters
such as whether humans are a significant
cause of global warming
or whether concealed carry laws increase
gun crime
and similar patterns of polarization can
be found around the world
the thing is that one prominent
explanation for why we are so
susceptible to fake news
why we polarize in this way appeals to
human irrationality
but of course irrationality poses a
threat to knowledge
if we manage to form true beliefs but do
so in an irrational way
our true beliefs are only as good as
lucky guesses and luck is the enemy of
knowledge
this is the first threat i'm going to
discuss the threat posed by
irrationality however irrationality is
not the whole story because it turns out
that we can be misled by fake news
and we can be led to polarize even
though we're irrational
sorry even though we're rational this
might seem like good news from the point
of view of knowledge
but unfortunately it's not because if
rational people systematically polarize
over factual beliefs
which are either true or false this
implies that the
rules of rationality are not a
particularly reliable way of getting it
the truth
so the second threat to knowledge i will
discuss is the threat posed by
rational polarization
the final threat that fake news poses to
knowledge that i'd like to discuss
is the threat from relativism this
threat stems not so much from the fact
that there's a lot of fake news about
but from a prevalent philosophical
approach that people seem to have
towards fake news and towards truth and
knowledge more broadly
to use a cliche the attitude is
sometimes called post-truth
but it's really a crude version of
relativism and this connects with issues
that i've been grappling with since i
went to graduate school
an example of this kind of crude
relativism is expressed in the alt-right
expressed by the alt-right internet
troll mike cernovich
in an interview i happened to read in
the new yorker in 2016.
so cernovich had been spewing out
massive quantities of
misinformation in the run-up to the 2016
presidential election in the u.s
much of which was targeted at hillary
clinton
and in the interview cernovich basically
acknowledges that not all of which he
posts is true
or is has been carefully vetted and he
clearly doesn't think that the truth or
evidence matters
what matters he seems to think is just
getting the message
out there persuading people to take up
his point of view
completely regardless of whether what he
says is true or supported by evidence
and he justifies this by saying quote
look i read postmodernist theory in
college if everything is narrative then
we need
alternatives to the dominant narrative
so according to this crude relativism
there's nothing
there's no such thing as objective truth
reason or knowledge
no such thing as fake news objectively
speaking
rather what's fake news and what's real
news all depends on your perspective
since there is no objective truth all
you can do is fight your corner
get your own narrative out there and
persuade as many as you can to join your
team
success is measured in numbers of tweets
and retweets
what's surprising about this new
development is that relativism has for a
long time been the darling of the left
particularly prevalent among left-wing
intellectuals in the humanities
reading that new yorker article about
the alt-right in fact took me right back
to grad school
where relativism seemed to be part of
the furniture
i did my phd at the department of
history and philosophy of science in
cambridge
in the midst of the relativistic turn in
the study of science
and relativism i think still strikes
many on the left
as a very attractive view so in the
rest of this lecture and in the next
lecture i'm going to discuss
each of these threats to knowledge in
turn
but i will spend most of my time on the
third i think that there are many people
on the left who react to the crude
relativism of the alt-right
and who want to defend truth reason and
democracy from this scourge
but given the power of relativism over
the popular imagination
it may be hard to find arguments against
it so
if you're one of those people who finds
relativism attractive
i hope to convince you that it's not and
if you're one of those people who finds
relativism unattractive
hopefully what i can do today is help
you out with some arguments against it
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas